I'm pleased to welcome back to the
program dr. Christopher De Carlo who's
an award-winning philosopher educator an
author of his latest book on critical
thinking called six steps to better
thinking how to disagree and get along
it's great to have you back you know
this is a topic that's very very
interesting to me and we've talked a lot
about sort of the discoveries that
behavioral economics has made over the
last several decades that oftentimes
when you present people you're arguing
with with sort of counter contradictory
information we would like to imagine
that they're going to see the light and
sort of change their mind but very very
often this is not actually the way it
goes and you talk in the book about how
to have some of those conversations and
not only get along but maybe be more
effective so let's start there what's a
good general principle to think about
when you're debating something like
politics with other people that disagree
right to me the first thing you have to
do is be aware of your own biases and
why you've arrived at your current
position and then to be able to wonder
why that other person is thinking
differently from you and what biases
might have led them to that same uh you
know opposing viewpoint and when you do
that the goal is what or I guess is your
goal or should your goal be to change
minds what would be the best approach
empirically speaking to have the best
shot at doing that right so if the art
of argumentation is trying to persuade
somebody of your particular position and
you're better aware of a your own biases
within the context of what the other
person's biases might be this goes a
long way towards trying to find some
type of medium point between where
you're both coming down and so it
becomes easier to try to reach out to
that person with whom you're disagreeing
and be able to communicate more clearly
and more effectively that's interesting
because in some cases the sword of truth
might be a middle ground between
two positions but very often that's not
the case right and I find that that's a
sort of a starting point for a lot of
people who say well listen this is the
position of one side and this is the
position of the other side and more than
likely we all have our biases and the
truth is sort of somewhere in the middle
but a lot of times that that's really
not the case right like the truth might
be the view that is typically subscribe
to by a political party or a particular
movement or an institution or whatever
the case may be so how do you deal with
that how do you deal with the reality
that very often the truth isn't just the
sort of average of all the positions
that are out there right so there are a
number of techniques that can be used in
cases like that you can use the Socratic
approach which I personally like where
in order to try to get somebody who has
opposing views about a position that you
you know and all perspectives is simply
wrong you can get them to talk through
it and what Socrates did is he started
off by agreeing with the person so it's
kind of like well let's assume that
you're right this is known as a reductio
ad absurdum let's assume that you're
right and let's follow along where your
propositions where your premise is Lee
and if you can try to get the person to
walk through their particular
understanding of a topic they themselves
might be able to see where it is they've
made you know a fallacy or a fallacious
form of reasoning so that's the Socratic
form another form is you try to find
shared values with the other person and
then try to appreciate coming at it from
the point of view of a shared value can
they can they see any way in which they
might question what they currently
believe and and better understand why it
is you hold your particular opinion so
those are two techniques that I use
what's your opinion of III I don't know
where this idea started and I don't
think it's original to Peter Bogosian
but he's popularized the DES feasibility
question right which is what evidence if
I could present you
with it would change your mind as sort
of a starting point to getting people to
think wait if the answer is there's no
evidence that would change my mind maybe
I'm not actually basing my opinion on
the evidence what's your opinion of that
strategy right it's it's not a bad
strategy but it immediately confronts a
person and what happens if you're
talking about cherished beliefs about
hot-button issues and a person already
has an enormous amount of emotional
baggage that they're bringing to that
that topic asking them that question
might not have much of an impact on them
if they've already invested so much
emotional activity into basically
maintaining that position so it could
have some efficacy in terms of getting
them to try to understand that if
they're not willing to consider the
possibility of being in error in any way
then then they have to admit that they
are dogmatist well all you've done is
really basically pointed out an obvious
fact that in case of say religious
belief or whatnot you're you really just
calling attention to the fact that
they're just going to say yeah and the
reason why I'm dogmatic is because I'm
right and I'm certain and you're the one
who has issue so sometimes it can help
but I don't know if it if it always will
be productive many of us have been
involved in political disagreements or
discussions where you can sort of sense
it and it's hard to say exactly when it
crosses the line but at a certain point
it gets tense and sometimes you notice
that you might be starting to get a
little hot in the underarms or there's
just something that you sort of sense
that the conversation has crossed from
sort of a friendly conversation into one
where people are starting to get upset
in your experience what causes it to
cross that line yeah I mean you really
kind of talking about you know elements
of randomness and
chaos where things can occur quite
unpredictably in terms of what might set
people off what might cause that kind of
you know emotional turmoil but not and
not so much specifically but what type
of shift in the conversation is what
usually gets to those discussions that
no longer feel okay oftentimes it's a
personal account so if you've struck a
nerve with somebody who has had very
personal experiences with whatever that
topic yet right if it's uh you're
talking about abortion gun control
euthanasia any any major topics the
aspect of politics
if a person has felt that within their
lives and now that somehow brought up
now that's often a case where you're
going to see somebody you know take a
bit of a turn towards more kind of
serious emotional issue or slant towards
the issue in your opinion are the
debates about religion and debates about
politics are they more similar or
different and in other words we could
say well they both relate to sort of
dogmas that one might subscribe to they
both relate to you know ideas that
people are emotionally invested in but
are they really similar types of
disagreement or as religion sort of its
own thing the difference with politics
and religion they're not always separate
but with with religion you have to
understand every time a very deeply
religious person gets up in the morning
they have in their minds the belief that
the information that they're in
possession of is reflective of what is
absolutely true about the nature of the
universe that's no small amount of
information and with politics that this
can vary you know a young man begins as
a liberal and you know enters middle age
and an old age as a conservative with a
with religion that's totally different
story you're talking about the fabric of
reality now you're talking about
something so strong within a person's
it's essentially there is no drug in
comparison with religious conviction I
mean that gets a person higher than any
drug could possibly get them and if
you're going to try to argue against
what it is that gets him that gets them
that high it's like taking the needle
from from the heroin addict or the
bottle from the alcoholic they're gone
often going to fight you on that because
this is what provides them with that
comfort you know feeling what I call
mimetic equilibrium where the world
makes sense the universe makes sense and
all of a sudden you you want to enter
into their worldview doubts and you know
the capacity for error and being wrong
or being misguided that's extremely
deleterious and harmful to their
particular worldview so that's how it
differs from from politics religion what
are the six steps to better thinking
that you outline in the book to dig into
that material a little bit more sure
very easy to remember the six steps
match the first six letters of the
alphabet so eight is for argument people
have to know how to formulate their
ideas into the form of an argument so
that they're better understood B is for
bias we have to understand why it is we
believe what we do and what led us to
this particular point in time
C is for context information doesn't
exist in a vacuum it's always embedded
within some particular type of context
ideas for diagram people and learn a
skill in which when they hear or see or
read what a person is saying there are
skills there are tools that allow them
to literally draw out what that argument
looks like so they can see it on paper
he is for evidence if you're going to
support your argument with evidence
there are various different types f is
for fallacies there's a lot of different
types of policies which are errors and
reasoning so this capacity allows us to
better identify when somebody is making
an error and reasoning and now we can
put a name to the face so to speak can
everybody learn this
and and if so is there sort of some
natural inclination to either be
comfortable in these engaging in these
types of disagreements discussions and
debates because I get a lot of people
who tell me listen I I sort of when I'm
on my own I like thinking about these
things and sort of thinking about what
my positions are on on whatever issue
but I am just not able to engage in a
back-and-forth with someone else and
it's not a question of knowledge of
facts it's just I
constitutionally I freeze up I can't do
it it's not for me do you think these
are skills anybody can learn of course
and their skills of empowerment I mean
I've been lobbying the Ontario
government here mm-hmm
easily the last five years and I've made
some headway with a pilot project with
one of the school school boards here in
Ontario to introduce critical thinking
skills into the curriculum or grades 9
and 10 so that if they can learn them at
those grades and then carry them forward
and grades 11 and 12 they will offer
them levels of empowerment where they
have the capacity now be able to better
understand why it is they believe what
they do so you know I've also visited
other countries as well throughout the
world I have a not-for-profit called a
critical thinking project and what we do
is we do we travel around the world or
we Skype around the world and we teach
teachers the basics of critical thinking
so that in other countries outside of
our own teachers and students can learn
these critical thinking skills and then
the plan is allow them to solve their
problems their way by using these
particular skills the book is six steps
to better thinking how to disagree and
get along we've been speaking with the
books author dr. Christopher de Carlo
thanks again for talking to me about
this and glad to have you back on the
program my pleasure at a time